the pandemic is impacting las vegas
strip properties over the next few weeks
we will be getting updates from gaming
companies
on the very last quarter of 2020. today
las vegas sands releasing its fourth
quarter earnings 8 news now reporter
kate houston live in our newsroom
to break down the impact this has had on
las vegas properties
and kate the road to recovery yes that's
right brian the las vegas sands
corporation is
down 2.4 billion dollars in net revenue
compared to the same time in 2019. the
company says
this is due to the monumental financial
impact of the pandemic
the company owns the venetian palazzo
and sands expo center
as well as properties in macau and
singapore although visitation during the
week in las vegas is
down sands says it's doing fairly well
on the weekends
the company adds there are some days
that they're almost at
2019 slot levels although group bookings
for this year have gone down
due to continuing restrictions las vegas
sands is confident in the demand moving
forward
our demand for 22-27 convention
is unbelievable our customers want to
come
and we remain very bullish on the return
of las vegas it may take while we want
to it may take
at the end of this year we see
visitations fight but
please don't be among those people who
have these ideas that you know this
pandemics have put a hole in las vegas
and just the opposite
in addition to conventions and loosening
restrictions
the company says there will need to be
more flights to las vegas
in order to recover and this was the
first earnings call since the passing of
ceo
and chairman sheldon adelson earlier
this month the team says
despite the hardship of the past year
they will move forward with the
creativity
and strategy that he was known for